إنه قرص مضاد للفيروسات يستخدم لعلاج
covid19 اعتبارًا من منتصف أغسطس في الولايات المتحدة ، تقول
وزارة الصحة والخدمات الإنسانية
إنه تم إعطاء حوالي أربعة ملايين دورة من
paxlevid ، لكن بعض
الأشخاص الذين تناولوا حبوب منع الحمل المضادة للفيروسات أظهروا
نتائج إيجابية للمرة الثانية التي
نعرفها  أن الأشخاص الأكبر سنًا هم أكثر
عرضة للانتعاش ، وقد تتبعت العديد من الدراسات
حالات الارتداد ، بما في ذلك
دراسة ما قبل الطباعة التي نظرت في الحالات
أثناء موجة أوميكرون ، ووجدت أن 2 إلى
4 في المائة من المرضى عانوا من
عدوى ارتدادية أو أعراض في غضون
أسبوع بعد العلاج خمسة  إلى ستة
بالمائة حصلوا على انتعاش في غضون شهر ، يقول الخبراء
أن حالات الارتداد ربما تكون أكثر
شيوعًا مما تظهره البيانات ، ولكن بمدى
صعوبة معرفة ذلك ، ولكن في نهاية
اليوم ، لم ينته أي من الحالات التي
ارتد فيها الارتداد إلى الحصول على المزيد
مرض شديد أو انتهى به المطاف في
المستشفى ، لذلك ما زلت أعتقد أن المنحدر الخلفي
دواء مفيد بشكل لا يصدق ولهذا السبب
يقول الخبراء إن إجمالي باكس ليفيت لا يزال
عملية جيدة  لعلاج الأشخاص الذين
تزيد أعمارهم عن 65 عامًا والذين يعانون من
نقص المناعة أو البالغين الذين يعانون من
حالات كامنة مثل مرض السكري
أو أمراض القلب في بيان قالت
شركة فايزر المصنعة باكسولفيد ، بينما
هناك حاجة إلى مزيد من التقييم ، نواصل
مراقبة البيانات من دراساتنا السريرية المستمرة.
واثق جدًا من
فعاليته السريرية والوقاية
من النتائج الوخيمة لـ covid19
والمرضى المعرضين لخطر متزايد على الصحة
دقيقة أنا ماندي غايثر